bonjour paul-elie merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france
alors comment expliquer la faible taux
de contamination au congrès us
actuellement en italie alors que les
chiffres continuent de grimper dans de
nombreux pays européens dont la france
quelle est la clé du miracle italiens
comme l'appellent les angoisses les
anglo saxons
je sais pas si c'est un miracle en tout
cas à la clé c'est le fait que vous
savez et vous pouvez les gouvernements
peuvent adopter et l'idée les mesures
les plus strictes au monde mais s'il n'y
a pas une vraie adhésion des citoyens à
ces mesures
ça sert strictement à rien la chose
assez étonnante en italie c'est que
toute la population avérée assez
rapidement à ces mesures est donc
aujourd'hui s'est installé dans un pays
qui généralement a été toujours un petit
peu allergique aux règles disons les
italiens ne sont pas exactement des
suisses
c'est impressionnant le niveau
d'adhésion et deux contrôles autres
citoyens aussi je vous fais un exemple
moi je suis passé un jour je suis parti
de paris à rome et j'avais et on me
recadrer à chaque seconde dans les bals
parce que j'avais une attitude qui était
assez laxiste alors que je je suis assez
attentif
donc il ya un vrai contrôle des citoyens
sur les citoyens
et dès qu'il ya un type qui est trop
près de thouars où coûter dans un bar
dans une mauvaise position exacte est
immédiatement recadre état le voisin qui
te dit avec attention monsieur 10 dont
il ya le virus l'ennemi invisible
donc on ne peut pas jeter la pierre
seulement sur le gouvernement sûr et
dire le gouvernement fait bien fait mal
les mesures sont plus ou moins
similaires en france comme le fait est
que cette bataille c'est une bataille
collectives mais aussi individuelles qui
revient responsabilité de chacun d'entre
nous et les italiens contre 7 ni
invisible se sont montrés vraiment pour
une fois très très très très rigoureux
et solidaire c'est pour ça aujourd'hui
on en voit les résultats quoique la
situation est presque toujours très très
fragile il faut pas on est à 1494 cale
dans les derniers
en 24 heures on est là il a signifié
d'ailleurs le président de la république
sir joe matar est là qui soutenaient ces
jours ci que les italiens aiment la
liberté de mouvement mais sont aussi
capables d'un grand esprit de sérieux
peut-on dire qu'il ya un certain
traumatisme qui s'est installé en italie
de cette pandémie
il ya certainement un traumatisme je
vous rappelle qu'on avait passé la barre
des 35 mille morts mais je me demande
pourquoi ce traumatisme devrait être
moins fort en france parce que je veux
dire en italie il ya eu 35 mille morts
mais en france il y en a pas eu beaucoup
moins on est à 31 me 32000 donc les
italiens effectivement été plus
traumatisées par par cette saignée et
aujourd'hui on les voit très très très
attentif en tout cas plus attentifs dans
notre pays européens c'est pour ça que
aujourd'hui la praille question c'est
d'instaurer et c'est ce dacquois
réfléchi angela merkel qui détient la
présidence de l'union européenne avec
tous les autres qui seraient d'accord
une sorte de quarantaine pour les pays
intra européennes pour les pays qui ils
ont l'écran malades l'europe qui
aujourd'hui sont les l'espagne et la
france donc quand il ya un taux
d'incidence ils ont de 300 cas sur dix
mille habitants ont fait on fait on
alors que la quarantaine pour les
citoyens de ces pays qui voudraient
venir en italie dans notre pays donc à
prendre exemple sur les méthodes
italiennes notamment sur la prise de
température systématique ou encore sur
le contrôle de beaucoup des flux c'est à
dire les entrées et sorties du pays 80 %
des vols qui viennent habituellement de
l'étranger sont tout simplement annulé
ce qu'il faut mettre en place ces
mesures en france
écoutez moi je vous dis seulement une
petite épisode que j'ai vécu
personnellement j'ai pris l'avion pour
aller de paris à rome avec alitalia donc
la compagnie italienne et il y avait
tous les fauteuils les espaces et c'est
à dire que moi à côté de moi j'avais
personnes
j'ai pris le même vol cette fois ci pour
revenir à paris air france et on était
tous comme un troupeau 1 sur l'autre
agglutinés avec nos masques bien sûr
mais appréciable
l'hôtesse qui passent très gentiment je
mets
en doute avec les sandwichs et pendant
une demi-heure tout le monde se lève le
masque et mange le sandwich tous
ensemble sur l'autre c'est quelque chose
d'une incohérence totale donc on ne peut
pas faire les donneurs de leçons mais il
faut faire très très attention parce que
c'est un ennemi invisible
on le voit pas mais plutôt qu'il faut
faire attention en france comme en
italie comme partout et sa famille si on
attend que cela soit l'étalement nous à
résoudre tous les problèmes
on est mal barré parce que c'est notre
bataille c'est notre responsabilité
individuelle à chacun d'entre nous donc
voilà c'est une bataille qu'on doit
mener avec les autorités mais nous mêmes
notre responsabilité individuelle il
doit faire attention tout simplement à
autrui et à nous mêmes c'est seulement
en défendant nous mêmes qu'on pourra
aussi défendre les autres et vice versa
voilà je pense que ça c'est une leçon
que les italiens en ont compris et
adopté assez rapidement et je le vois un
peu moins d'un an dans d'autres pays ça
sera le mot de la fin merci beaucoup
paolo levi d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
correspondant de l'agencé presse en deçà
en france